bueno es muy grave estamos ante una
situación muy dolorosa y profundamente
anti derechos en este momento se anulan
dos presentes que con fundamentales para
el acceso al auto y para el
reconocimiento de los derechos
reproductivos en eeuu de forma federal
lo que quiere decir que en este momento
queda en la potestad de cada uno de los
estados en eeuu regular y legisladores
de temas para poder entender cómo va a
quedar digamos el territorio de eeuu
frente al acceso al aborto y esto pues
es muy grave porque sabemos que al menos
la mitad de los estados en eeuu estarían
buscando
restringir el acceso al aborto a través
de iniciativas legislativas para poner
límites de tiempo para poder acceder por
ejemplo y que al menos unos 12 estados
podrían podrían estar pensando en
prohibirlo
totalmente esto sin lugar a dudas
representa una falta de garantías a las
mujeres una falta de garantías de sus
derechos más fundamentales
y derechos con los que crecieron durante
los últimos 50 años y que hoy se ponen
en riesgo con esta decisión de la corte
sobre bueno y justamente le pregunto a
qué se debe que la corte suprema haya
hecho esta revisión de los fallos en
estos momentos de la historia
pues realmente esta decisión que no se
no se puede entender desde un punto de
vista derechos como yo lo decía al
principio de mi intervención es una
decisión profundamente anti derechos
porque el derecho al aborto existió en
eeuu hasta el día de hoy y a través de
una interpretación que se hace de la
enmienda 14 del artículo sobre la
libertad y la privacidad que se
encuentra ahí y que es el mismo artículo
demás que se ha usado para por ejemplo
avanzar en el reconocimiento del
matrimonio interracial el reconocimiento
del matrimonio de las personas del mismo
sexo y pues por supuesto el derecho de
las mujeres a votar entonces hoy en día
vemos cómo se retrocede y se retrocede
porque tenemos una corte en donde el
antiguo presidente de eeuu logra nombrar
a tres jueces antes de salir con una
visión profundamente anti derechos que
se refleja al día de hoy en esta
decisión bueno algo que llama mucho la
atención tiene que ver con lo que están
a lo que está llamando el fiscal general
lo que está llamando el presidente yo
vaivén están diciendo que hay un refugio
en los estados demócratas donde se va a
proteger este derecho pero es que no
todas las mujeres tienen las condiciones
sociales o económicas o incluso
culturales para poder desplazarse a
otros estados qué pasa con las mujeres
que están en las minorías con las
mujeres que por pertenecer a
determinadas culturas por ejemplo no
pueden salir de estos territorios
claro y ese es el grave el grave impacto
y las graves consecuencias que va a
tener esta decisión porque si bien es
cierto que las mujeres podrían
destaparse de un estado al otro para
encontrar el servicio la gran mayoría no
va a poder hacerlo porque recordemos
quiénes son la mayoría de las mujeres
que buscan un aborto en eeuu son las
mujeres más jóvenes son mujeres que
viven debajo de la línea de pobreza en
la gran mayoría son mujeres racializada
son mujeres migrantes entonces qué va a
pasar con estas mujeres lo que vamos a
ver en eeuu es lo que hemos vivido
durante décadas en latinoamérica
situaciones trágicas y dolorosas como
mujeres que van a tener que buscar
abortos clandestinos muchas veces
inseguros poniendo en riesgo su vida o
su salud en niñas víctimas de violación
sexual kahn a tener que seguir adelante
con embarazos a muy tempranas edades y
esto al final se va a volver un problema
de salud pública en unos años vamos a
ver un gran problema de salud pública
como los índices de mortalidad materna
van a empezar a crecer y bueno realmente
es profundamente preocupante lo que está
pasando